Doing that with you,
I've actually never done that with
another actor, but I've never played
the same role.
The same person.
How have you felt so far
working with me?
Mostly behind the scenes.
Yeah, I mean the most fun thing
to do was on my days off
is when I'd have the opportunity
to come watch you guys.
We still have not worked
together, technically.
Not really.
No one wants to see
the Kurt Russell and Wyatt Russell combos.
Thank God for Godzilla!
We both get to work with Godzilla.
He fails to hit his marks,
never knows his lines,
but the sh*t he can do with his mouth?
He's incredible.
Being in the business
for as long as you have,
still being the most
excited person on set,
Hoo-ah!
It's fun for me to see my dad
be that person for other people.
Hell of a job, co-pilot.
How many fathers and sons
have that opportunity?
Yeah, you got that right.
I'm just really glad we did it.
It was fun. It was great.
I had a ball with you.
Yeah me too.